president Trump meets with House
Republicans today facing growing out
outrage over his zero-tolerance
immigration policy Department of
Homeland Security figures show two
thousand three hundred and forty two
children were separated from parents at
the border from May 5th to June ninth
the Trump administration still insists
Congress is responsible while more
Republicans are speaking out against the
administration policy at O'Keefe is on
Capitol Hill at good morning good
morning guys the president is meeting
with GOP lawmakers today to talk about
broader issues of immigration policy not
just those families separated at the
border there are two competing proposals
on the table that the house is set to
vote on this week but neither has even
enough Republican support to pass right
now that could change today if the
president endorses either plan there's
now also a separate proposal from
Republican Texas senator Ted Cruz that
would reunite those families his plan
would among other things authorize new
temporary shelters double the number of
immigration judges reunite those
families and ensure that asylum seekers
are processed within 14 days whether or
not Cruz can actually find enough
support for this among Democrats remains
unclear but the fact that it would
reunite those families and address
long-held concerns about a backlog of
asylum case that suggests it might have
a chance Alex thanks a lot of eyes on
that legislation today